en confrontation qu'il redoutait après
avoir longuement témoigné hier à la
barre isabelle et jean pierre foucault
se disent libéré d'un poids
mais il compte bien aller au bout de
leur combat pour obtenir enfin de
johnatan d'aval toute la vérité
moi j'étais soulagé de parler mais ça
veut pas dire que le procès avance comme
a dit jean-pierre et au vu de ce qu'a
dit l'expert ce matin il à la toute
puissance et sa toute puissance à lui
c'est de garder encore des secrets
c'est le procès de jonathan on l'a dit
mais hier lorsque vous avez pris la
parole on a le sentiment que vous
vouliez aussi raconté alexia que les
gens qui ne la connaissent pas en fait
tu saches qui elle était oui parce que
c'est ce que je dis aux jours de la
garde à vue l'avocat disait qu alex
avait déjà une personnalité écrasante
j'apprenais que c'était mon gendre
meurtrier et depuis ce jour là j'ai
énormément souffert de ça c'est pas mon
alexia je veux dire cet avocat s'est
permis de dire des choses en ne sachant
rien il ne connaissait pas notre enfant
il est vraiment encore m alexia là où
elle doit être
c'est elle la belle personne c'est elle
la victime depuis l'ouverture du procès
les journées sont longues et éprouvantes
pour les parents d'alexia et comme
chaque jour depuis la disparition de
leur fille ils tiennent bon grâce au
soutien de leur famille on n'aurait
jamais pu devenir trois ans tous les
deux c'est impossible
le réconfort de tout le monde de toute
la famille a été constant pendant ces
trois années
malheureusement nous n'avons pas pu
amener toutes les personnes désireuses
de participer à cette horreur de procès
la famine ou sans famille on tient pas
avant le verdict qui pourrait être
prononcé dans la soirée de vendredi
isabelle et jean pierre foucault espère
pouvoir s'adresser une dernière fois à
johnattan